et puis fin de la compétition de l'open
de golf de france ce sera dimanche à un
tout autre sujet le 30 juin
l évêque de versailles monseigneur
omonia ordonné huit prêtres dans pour
les yvelines alors c'est une année
d'ailleurs que l'évêché qualifie de
records parce qu'en 2012 ils n'étaient
que 2 et parmi ces huit prêtres vous
souriez quand je dis record mais c'est
ce qu'on m'a dit parmi les huit
printemps dernier il y avait vous le
père eric duverdier bonsoir vous
officiez dans les paroisses de la vallée
de chevreuse alors je me dis quand on
est ordonné prêtre comme ça c'est
vraiment l'aboutissement d'un long
processus
vous avez 29 ans parlez nous un peu de
ce processus parce que votre parcours
religieux est assez atypique
oui c'est vrai alors c'est
l'aboutissement vous dites c'est
l'aboutissement d'un long processus
c'est aussi le début d'un encore plus
l'eau enfin est-ce que c'est maintenant
que tout va se faire mais c'est vrai que
pour ma part voilà c'est j'achève
maintenant cette année deux formations
qui se sont déployés alors à la fois un
bout dans les yvelines je vous avais dit
tout à l'heure les trois premières
années de ma formation
et puis ensuite j'ai terminé dans le
vaucluse où je suis encore actuellement
je vais y retourner d'ailleurs à la
rentrée oui oui et puis vous vous
destiniez à la logistique aux relations
inter saison c'est vrai et en 2006 ont
poussé la porte voilà oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai alors oui alors des équipes
qui se fait en plusieurs temps c'est en
plusieurs temps et d'ailleurs la manière
dont le parcours s'est passé le montre
d'abord enfants
le jour de ma première communion à la
basilique de montmartre puisque j'ai
préparé ma première communion montmartre
parce que j'ai vu le prêtre le vélo
stygi vivement cette conviction
intérieure plus tard je serai comme lui
bon et puis l'adolescence est passée par
là le sous marin qui se pose
tranquillement au fond de l'océan qui
prend la vase etc
et puis à la fin de mon lycée quand même
cette question qui revient cette
question qui revient et puis le
responsable de la formation des
séminaristes dans le diocèse prend acte
mais me demande d'aller faire des études
donc je commence une école de commerce
je pars à angers je fais 5 en master 2
en logistique et achats internationaux
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
et puis pendant toutes ces années ce
vote la question restée un peu en
suspens j'ai comme voilà j'ai profité à
fond de ma vie d'étudiant je commence à
travailler le milieu professionnel je
lui prenais goût j'étais bon là donc ma
vie commence à ce tracé vraiment à
l'issue de deux de ses cinq années je
commençais à travailler voilà il était
temps j'avais à dire je vous avais dit
tu as l'air aussi j'avais accompli tous
mes rêves d'enfant j'avais un job voulu
fonder une famille ce n'aurait pas été
un problème à ce moment là j'avais peur
du coup c'est quoi le déclic c'est quoi
le déclic c'est c'est la question qui
revient tout le temps à cette question
qui revient tout le temps de jeu vous
disais tout à l'heure ce se jetait mme
keen qui nécessite une réponse qu'on
peut pas laisser en suspens et et 1 et
un je t'aime tellement grand qu'il faut
y répondre avec un grand aussi je t'aime
et ce je t'aime pour moi ça a été le don
de ma vie complet de toute ma vie parce
que là c'est un choix c'est un choix
vraiment c'est un choix qui est une
réponse à un appel
c'est à dire c'est cette conviction
intérieure forte qui petit tapis envahi
complètement s'impose de telle manière
que il devient évident que la voie du
bonheur
la voie de l'accomplissement de soi la
voix du plus grand service de tous ceux
qui qui qui qui vivent aujourd'hui et
que j'aurai à croiser dans mon parcours
c'est celui de me donner complètement à
dieu dans les mains de l'église pour
servir le peuple veut sereine on a vu
maj effectivement votre ordination avec
les os les sept autres prêtres qu'est ce
que vous avez ressenti à ce moment là
j'ai ressenti ce sens fier parce que je
prends les parcours c'est long il frappe
à la porte du cimetière c'est à une
formation d'un an
c'est une formation qui est assez longue
en plus vous avez eu la l'année où
l'année de fondation la dernière année
de formation puis après trois en deux
ans c'est long là on se dit ouah ça y
est c'est alors on se dit alors on se
dit oh c'est vrai on s'y est préparé
pendant des années et on y est ça c'est
sûr moi ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé au
cours de cette de cette célébration
c'est de sentir la prière de tout le
peuple chrétien ya plus de deux mille
deux mille cinq cents personnes réunies
dans cette cathédrale qui a tendance à
s'emporter c8 prêtre portait sous
vraiment vraiment et et de sortir dans
ce regard des gens sortir dans cette
prière qui montait dans les voûtes de
cette cathédrale le désir du peuple
chrétien d'avoir des pasteurs à son
service des jeunes qui acceptent de tout
abandonner contre la logique du monde
c'est vrai qu'ils acceptent de tout
abandonner pour se mettre au service de
dieu et se mettre à leur service
parce que c'est ça aussi notre vie c'est
être au service de ses eaux qui auprès
desquels on est envoyé et le sentir que
ces chrétiens son désir de cela nous
attendent sont prêts à nous soutenir à
s'engager avec nous à marcher avec nous
à entrer dans notre dynamique pour qu'on
avance ensemble qu'on fasse un peuple et
qu'on avance éric toile pour parler de
la notion de service à voir ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui en 2013 à votre avis
qu'est ce que la religion catholique
peut apporter dans le quotidien des gens
qu'est ce qu'elle peut apporter dans le
quotidien des gens un sens
c'est un sens un sens dans le sens des
réponses à des questions ne marche pas
on ne marche pas à l aveugle on peut se
lever le matin et même justin un pied
devant l'autre
c'est sûr mais je pense qu'à certains
moments et souvent ça se produit au
moins deux d'événements forts dans la
vie on dit mais pourquoi pourquoi je vis
comme ça quel est le sens de ma vie quel
est son but
vers quoi je marche qu'est ce qui me
motive quel est le moteur l'intérieur de
ma vie et celui ci ça s'est un peu mais
ça je voulais faire passer à vos
paroissiens
alors je pense que et j'espère que c'est
que ce que je vis moi et ceux qui
désirent vivre aussi et que c'est
rencontre là peut nous peut nous peut
créer une espèce d'étincelles vivifiante
si vous voulez parce que j'ai pas dit
c'est que là vous a été ordonné prêtre
maltaise avait encore fait le choix
d'une année d'enseignement n'est que
vous officiez on peut dire à mi temps je
passe encore ces mêmes c'est un peu
moins que mi temps pour moi même temps
que simplement cabinet vous fixant le
week-end et le reste de la semaine je
continue à avoir une vie d'étudiant en
fait eu un rythme étudiant en théologie
en théologie anthropologie j'ai étudié
l'anthropologie ses effectifs alors ça
vous allez en tout cas dans les rues de
saint quentin pour elle pour montrer aux
gens de répondre à la question que je
vous ai posé
qu'est ce que la religion catholique
peut apporter dans votre vie au
quotidien aurait écouté les réponses
écoutez bien j'en attends que qu'elle se
met plus en avant des problèmes réels
que ceux plus près de la réalité de la
société élabore la saleté contrôlé puis
le bien-être
abbas alors je vois mal qu'est ce
qu'elle peut faire un déjà le pape fait
pas mal de choses apparemment pour les
polémiques les plus démunis etc
c'est ce que l'église devrait toujours
faire quoi voilà rien du tout qu'elle
fasse que les hommes soient bons et
généreux entre moins qu'au bal ce serait
mieux
plus rien depuis longtemps pourquoi à
une grande déception en revanche j'adore
les aigus
donc je vais très souvent dans les
églises parce qu'elles sont vides
en revanche le côté
mais ce prêtre voilà tout ça ça ne
correspond absolument pas j'ai fait un
chemin différent
j'attends pas grand chose non parce que
j'estime que elle fait plus de mal que
de bien défendre tout ce qui est lié aux
valeurs aujourd'hui dans lesquelles mme
roy vous avez vu c'est très partagés à
willencourt des propos assez acide eux
mêmes par rapport à l'église elle fait
plus de mal que de bien
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
répondre à ce monsieur ne sais pas à
quoi il fait référence mais bon j'ai
payé des ailes fait plus de mal que de
bien
c'est vrai qu'on de toute façon le mal
fait toujours plus de bruit que bien
donc forcément on en parle plus le bien
il se diffuse ici il se diffuse dans les
petites choses du quotidien dans la
réalité les plus concrètes
je ne sais pas si ces gens là peu savent
où se trouve situé le bureau du secours
catholique dans leurs paroisses par
exemple et voit le nombre de dizaines de
centaines peut-être même de personnes
qui passent chaque jour deux de nos
paroissiens plus ou moins pratiquants
c'est vrai parce qu'il faut pas il faut
pas non plus en faire des amalgames
mais qui sont prêts à consacrer deux
trois cinq dix quinze heures de leur
journée pour aider tous ceux qui en ont
besoin
combien se soucient qu'on a partagé la
mise à disposition même de nos
ressources pour que effectivement on
construire ensemble un monde meilleur et
justement dans le micro trottoir il y
avait une personne ne se parlait du pape
il va parler un peu votre avis aussi sur
ce pape françois qui peut être être un
peu différent des autres pape qu'on a
connue d'abord parce que l'idée sud
américain mais quand ça terrain disait
il faut aider les plus démunis est ce
que c'est aussi un axe important de
votre engagement
ça c'est évidemment la charge une chose
dans mon parcours que j'avais pas
mentionné pendant cinq ans en fait avant
d'autres séminaires j'ai été secourues
sera animateur à la protection civile de
paris et j'ai aussi travaillé pour le
samu social dans ce cadre là beaucoup et
ça a été une des choses extrêmement
porteuses dans mon parcours
ce désir de de me mettre au service de
ceux qui en ont besoin et surtout des
plus défavorisés c'est quelque chose qui
était lancinant mon parcours et c'est
quelque chose que je n'ai pas abandonné
aujourd'hui et ça fait partie de mon
engagement
ça fait partie du don de ma vie c'est
clair 1 quel regard vous portez sur ce
pape françois boucq papa françois vous
avez beaucoup d'affection avait été
formé mais sous le pape benoît 16 10ème
débuts dans les préparant son entretien
que vous avez grandi avec
j'ai grandi avec jean paul le g7 où sa
formation sans cesse et d'avoir d'abord
beaucoup d'affection beaucoup
d'affection j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
cet homme qui arrive avec une autre
manière de voir les choses et de faire
qui peut nous déstabiliser nous de notre
vieille europe
on n'a pas du tout les mêmes manières de
faire d'être au quotidien et qui en même
temps a toujours eu le souci de ne
jamais faire une table table rase il le
montre l'encyclique qui publiera demain
il a dit dans une très belle conférence
de presse cet énoncé dite écrite à
quatre mains
il reçoit le travail fourni par benoît
il leur panse ensemble ils leur travail
ensemble 124 geôles souci de 2
d'aller de l'avant d'apporter du mieux
du plus effectivement une autre manière
de voir les choses d'une autre manière
de les vivre une vivacité une
disponibilité à aller coûte au contact
avec chacun un regard posé un échange au
coin d'un couloir saddam d'une profonde
humanité comme l'était ses prédécesseurs
à d'autres on le voyait moins un point
peut-être certains modèles pour vous on
vous en parlait beaucoup de chaleur en
tout cas j'avais une dernière question
quand on s'engage comme ça vous allez
dis c'est un show c'est un choix de vie
et c'est un choix pour toute la vie
est-ce qu'on n'a pas parfois peut-être
la question est peut-être vous heurter
mais est ce qu'on n'a pas un défaut des
doutes
si on n'a pas un doute sur cet
engagement on va donner à dieu alors
qu'on aurait pu s'engager autrement dans
la vie civile comme vous l'avez dit se
marier avoir des enfants du
professionnel alors je je il ya une
chose qui est sûre c'est que lui ne me
fera jamais défaut donc en termes de
doute s'allume déjà au moins 50% du
problème qui est l'autre d'accord et
donc de ce côté là un peu frais vous
êtes sûr de pas être déçu annonçant les
micro trottoirs des agents qui étaient
justement été déçu à ces arbres mais ça
c'est certain qu'il ne m'a jamais déçu
qu'il ne me déçoit pas maintenant et je
suis certain qu'ils ne me décevra jamais
alors c'est qui ne maman donnera jamais
et quand vous avez ras toujours tout ça
dont je savais comment les réponses de
votre engagement
voilà quand on n'est pas des exactement
on est prêt à s'engager merci beaucoup à
perdre et verdier d'être venu ce plateau
pour parler de votre bonne continuation
j'avais une dernière question ça me
permet transition est ce que vous vous
autorisez des vacances quand on est
prêtre anglais bien sûr d'action
nécessaire il faut y font merci